[Musique]
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue dans sa
zone
kadi avec notre invité ce matin alex
granville bonjour belge automatique a
coûté martinique 1ère très bien alors
vous êtes le coordinateur du comité 13
janvier 2020 un collectif qui lutte pour
la défense un qui soutient la défense de
des droits de militants notamment anti
chlordécone comme comme on dit en tout
cas qui des militantes donc qu'ils
veulent voir la justice passé dans dans
ce dossier qui nous concerne l' usage de
du chlordécone et puis bien sûr il ya
d'autres aspects alors vous êtes encore
vous le comité 13 janvier 2020 et vous à
l'extra ville dans une sorte de bras de
fer juridico politico sociétal on va
dire avec des relais ici de l'état
français et du pouvoir en place en ce
moment hier vous rencontriez la presse
pour souligner ce que vous considérez à
votre sens comme une escalade de la
répression dans notre pays martinique
alors qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser cela
allait xavier le comité 13 janvier 2020
a été créée de manière significative à
la veille du procès du 13 janvier 2020
contre les sept d'océanis notre démarche
fondamentale vise à apporter une
solidarité à tous les militants athées
victimes de la répression
policière judiciaire et des gendarmes
il est clair que à travers ce choix nous
nous exposons à des situations où
relativement difficile pour autant nous
considérons que l'année 2020 a marqué
toute une série de procès frappant des
militants en janvier en février en mai
en juillet en septembre en novembre et
nous recommençons une année 2021 avec
une espèce d'escaladé puisque au moment
où nous parlons
il y à de très nombreux procès dans le
mois de mars précisément hier nous avons
voulu indiquer aux martiniquais que les
actions qui sont menées qu'elle vise à
éclaircir le paysage culturel à travers
le nettoyage des statuts qu'elle vise à
éclaircir le paysage social en refusant
que aujourd'hui encore deux ans après
que le président à mâcon et indiqué
l'urgente nécessité de faire disparaître
le pavillon coloniale aux quatre
serpents qu'il est inacceptable que des
personnes continuent à faire cette
apologie de ce crime et surtout que
l'empoisonnement des martiniquais de 92%
de la population auclert descottes est
un problème qui est qui vise tout le
monde est contre lequel ne devons nous
mobiliser
alors alex granville sur le fond vous le
savez certainement une grande partie de
la population jette un oeil plutôt
favorables sur les actions que vous avez
entreprises mais d'un autre côté il y a
aussi d'autres actions des actes factuel
bondon c'est vrai les pouvoirs publics
ont leur lecture par le prisme du cadre
juridique de la lecture du droit un pur
pour aller vite mais il ya une partie
aussi de la population vous n'y aurait
pas certainement qui s'interroge si ce
n'est pas pour certains disent qu'ils
n'adhèrent pas notamment dans la façon
de faire dans le mode et qui disent que
finalement la violence appelle la
violence et peut-être qu'on peut qu'on
peut réclamer des droits sans forcément
peut-être aller casser ici ou là je
laissais d'utiliser des termes qui ne
soit pas le sens qu'il va ce pas
justement nous sommes dans un système
colonial la violence c'est le système
colonial ce système qui fait partie en
toute la jeunesse martiniquaise qui est
censée construire ce pays
ce système qui fait que 40% de la
population est dans des situations
sociales extrêmement difficile c'est là
qu'est la violence donc sans cadre
général que vous dénoncez aussi un cadre
systémique en c'est insensé de 4
systémiques auxquelles toute une
fraction de la population s'oppose et
l'opposition verbale et
aujourd'hui traduite par des actes que
des jeunes considèrent qu' il faut
qu'ils soient entendus que des salariés
considèrent qu'il faut qu'ils nous
revendique que des martiniquais
considère qu'il faut qu'on éclaircisse
le paysage culturel économique social ça
c'est fondamental
oh quelle est la réponse de l'état par
rapport à cela
une violence qui frappe toute personne
qui essaie de revendiquer quoi que ce
soit c'est pas possible qu'aujourd'hui
on considère que des gendarmes frappe
des militants
quant à mme may a revendiqué la manière
de revendiquer quand il ya un groupe qui
va effectivement donc se rend par
exemple dans la boutique la de la
fameuse marque de rhum pour finalement
s'en prendre aux biens matériels
il ya une plainte qui a été déposée pour
extorsion de signature je crois bon vous
comprenez que la population une partie
de la population en tout cas peut
émettre au moins quelques réserves
juridiques aux acquêts il n'y a pas de
réserve à émettre là dessus
ce n'est pas la première action sur les
modalités vous dites non sur la moralité
à s'interroger
nous n'avons pas à prendre en compte une
nous une manière de voir des propriétés
haut d'une distillerie qui par leur
statut au considère qu' ils n'ont aucun
contrat dans la population martiniquaise
parce que les militants ont déjà
traversé plusieurs espaces économiques
dans lesquelles ils ont échangé avec les
personnes qui étaient en infraction
parce que c'est là l'infraction ce sont
les boutiques qui sont en infraction de
faire l'apologie de crimes contre
l'humanité et lorsque les militants se
présente il demande aux personnes de
rectifier cette effraction en enlevant
les produits frappés du cap serpent et
ça se passe sans aucun problème puisque
il y a eu des engagements des
propriétaires des boutiques de dire si
un document
nous nous engageons à retirer les
produits qu'il faut apologie de crime
contre l'esclavagé aujourd'hui on est
devant une situation où un goût qui est
le groupe gbh considère qu'il n'a pas de
comptes à rome donc quand on leur dit
retirer les produits et accepter de vous
engager à ne pas le faire ils vont
imaginer une plaie
contre des camarades et dans la foulée
c'est là qu'est le problème la justice
la gendarmerie
loin de constater l'infraction fait par
ses propriétaires interpellent des
militants est pour l'instant
alors ok donc pour vous il ya deux poids
deux mesures en fait le fondamental mans
deux poids deux mesures dans la justice
vis-à-vis des militants et la justice
vis-à-vis de ces popularité dans tout ça
comment comment on en sort parce qu'on
al'impression contre les causes et des
conséquences la qui se rejettent les uns
sur les autres
qui qui s'affrontent qu'on est rentré
dans un cercle infernal un petit peu de
2,2 de vendetta ou deux où deux
guérillas finalement entre c'est le
temps et puis nous sommes dans un cadre
le pouvoir leurs revendications de notre
existence
duel sociale politique
à partir de là il appartient à chacun de
prendre en compte cette démarche et
surtout de ne pas nous mettre au bout de
l'est au fusil en nous déclarant une
guerre on sait ce que l'état fait avec
son institution judiciaire avec sa
police avec sa gendarmerie
nous considérons que respecter le droit
de manifester des personnes et quelque
chose auquel on ne peut pas déroger
lorsque nous voyons que en quinze années
de procédure il n'y a pas eu dans des
coudes dans la plainte déposée pour
contrôler la broye zone mot chlordécone
et qu'en quinze jours des militants sont
arrêtés suite à une plaie du groupe gbh
nous considérons que ça montre la
disproportion entre eux
la justice appelée obliqué et l'âge de
s'appliquer aux militaires d'ajustement
comme vous avez lâché le mot avant de
parler du calendrier judiciaire qui qui
arrive un notamment déjà un premier
rendez vous le 17 mars
parmi vos objecteurs alex granville et
vous êtes coordinateur le rappel du
comité 13 janvier 2020 il y en a qui
présente l'argument d'une forme de
racialisation de la lutte du combat que
vous menez à l'heure où d'autres bons à
tort ou à raison de manière plus ou
moins sincères peut-être à vos yeux mais
à l'heure où d'autres en martinique
d'autres qui se considère d'ailleurs qui
se disent martiniquais monde et quelques
beke disent vouloir faire des efforts
pour mieux vivre ensemble en dépassant
les traumatismes du passé
les propositions des béquilles sur le
mieux vivre ensemble les atteintes par
louis de certains vise à perpétuer une
domination
parce qu'aujourd'hui s'il y avait de la
part du pouvoir et des békés une volonté
de vivre ensemble donc de mettre d'abord
l'humanité en avant on l'aurait vu dans
des instances
pratique donc vous les chefs de ces
hommes qui seraient des partisans vous
dit de ce point de vue il faut résumer
parce qu'il faut qu'on parle du
calendrier oui vous donné que les actes
suivent les paroles que ce n'est pas
qu'il y ait dans un qu'il y ait des
lorsque nous verrons les quatre
martinique est majoritaire dans le
groupe bernard hayot nous saurons que il
y à un vivre ensemble qui commence
lorsque nous verrons des chefs de
service de l'état majoritaire
martiniquais nous saurons qui lie à une
volonté de vivre ensemble voilà que que
les paroles soient suivies des actes
d'actes concrets alors le 17 mars alors
on sait qu'il ya le 24 mars le procès de
quatre militants devant le tribunal
correctionnel de fort de france le 25
christian le logis le gilet jaune comme
il est surnommé procès lui il a fait
appel d'une première condamnation depuis
le 17 mars
il y à la sphère du jeune keziah qui
arrive alors qu'est ce que la cagnotte
oui la sphère du jeune keziah cette
affaire a été dépaysée comme a été
dépaysée le procès contre eux le préfet
cazelles sur les ananas sa considère que
le procureur de la république marc
précisément des choix dans son
traitement des dossiers judiciaires ce
qui concerne des blancs des européens
des français sont des paysans france
parce qu'il sort de la responsabilité de
l'équitabilité devant la justice pour
chacun et les militants sont frappés
prison systématique
la règle veut que la liberté soit la
règle et l'emprisonnement l'exception au
pour les militants systématiquement il y
à des demandes de prison alors par
rapport à ce calendrier quels seront vos
prochaines actions en tout cas sur les
modes on vous donne pas de nous dire
précisément ce que ce que vous comptez
faire mais on a bien compris que mon la
lutte continue pour vous oui de manière
précise nous appelons d'abord les
militants à nous rejoindre
vendredi à 18 heures devant la prison
pour exprimer notre solidarité à tous
les camarades emprisonnés
l'élu et volcans nous appelons les
martiniquais à apporter leur solidarité
dans les différents procès le 18 des 4
le 24
le 24 et le 25 et surtout le 17 mars
finalement si vous l'avez dire le 17 mai
j'ai dit que l'affairé a été dépaysée
donc à partir de là ça signifie que il a
amassé dépaysé vous vous allez peut-être
manifester quand même nous et devant
notre solidarité et surtout ne
l'expriment haut à travers la diaspora
martiniquaise qui est sensibilisé et qui
est prête à se mobiliser
bon ben voilà on a bien compris que
c'est pas complètement terminée donc à
bientôt
c'est surtout que nous voulons appeler
l'ensemble des martiniquais à ne pas
faire de saucissonnage en toi telle ou
telle ou telle méthode de revendiquer et
surtout de se considérer comme étant
impliqué dans ce combat qui est un
combat pour notre dignité
voilà notre invité ce matin était alex
qu'en ville coordinateur du comité 13
janvier 2020 bonne journée
[Musique]